they don't reflect like they're
promiscuous but unhappy they're on birth
control unhappy they're climbing the
corporate ladder unhappy why why no
self-reflection in the process do you
think
um I just kind of have a different view
on it I just want to take I just think
they liked the party life I just think
it was fun you know what I mean like
okay maybe how many girls do you really
know that are really climbing the
corporate ladder I mean you maybe you
think you lived in New York right maybe
you knew more of them but I'm like most
girls that I know just have average jobs
and most girls in general have average
jobs they're not climbing anything yeah
I know a lot of girls that are trying
that are trying to compete with men like
in the cities and I grew up with a lot
of them that were like I want to be the
manager I want to be the CEO I want to
be like that's that's a sign that I've
been successful in life and they they
four went having children for a really
long time in order to do that so I think
they exist and